und jetzt das heute journal
berlin heute abend nach langem zögern
zaudern darüber wie ein jahrzehntelanger
einsatz zu ende gehen soll heute endlich
eine ehrung und jemand mitgefühl für die
kraft von gesten hat dafür keine
etablierten würdenträger aufs podium
gebracht
guten abend wer weiß wofür der anfangs
peinliche tanz um die ehrung der
soldaten gut war wer weiß ob gleich nach
dem ersten ende der afghanistan mission
vor 15 wochen vor der rückkehr der
taliban an die macht vor der
dramatischen evakuierungs operationen
und mitten in der hitze des wahlkampfes
so deutlich selbstkritische worte der
politik und der anerkennung für die
leistungen von soldatinnen und soldaten
möglich gewesen wären wie heute gleich
werden wir im gespräch mit der
scheidenden ministerin sehen wie weit
das geht zunächst andrea maurer über
taten und worte heute in berlin
im mittelpunkt des großen zapfenstreichs
heute zwei einsatzsoldaten
oberstabsfeldwebel jens podolski
insgesamt 1700 tage am hindukusch
stationiert und oberstabsarzt in
katharina sigl dreimal im afghanistan
einsatz beide waren 2011 dabei als ein
kamerad in einer sprengfalle sein leben
verlor es sind diese bilder die vom ende
des 20 jährigen einsatzes bleiben sollen
schon beim abschluss appell am
nachmittag steht über allem die
sinnfrage
20 jahre nach dem elften september und
zwei monate nach dem fall von kabul
stellen viele menschen die in
afghanistan gedient und gelitten haben
fragen
fragen nach dem sinn dieses einsatzes
sind schwierige fragen
sind bittere fragen es geht bei den
bitteren fragen auch um die versäumnisse
der politik das versäumnis den einsatz
zu einem geordneten ende gebracht zu
haben das versäumnis die soldaten schon
bei ihrer rückkehr angemessen gewürdigt
zu haben
als am 30 juni die vorerst letzten
soldaten heimkehren ist kein politisch
verantwortlicher vor ort
wochen später folgen die bilder einer
chaotischen evakuierung operation in
kabul nichts ist gut in afghanistan
am ende scheint auch die politik bereit
zur ehrlichkeit denn eines können ja
müssen wir feststellen
deutschlands anspruch in afghanistan war
größer als das was die bundeswehr hätte
leisten können mehr als 150000
soldatinnen und soldaten hat das
deutsche parlament in den einsatz
geschickt
59 von ihnen haben ihr leben verloren
die meisten bei selbstmordattentaten in
hinterhalten in gefechten
kranzniederlegung am ehrenmal der
bundeswehr
die frage bleibt was aus der politischen
ehrlichkeit folgt
die abgeordneten die sie in diesen
einsatz geschickt haben haben gelernt
der vorteil der auftrag konnte so nicht
erfüllt werden wie wir es erhofft hatten
das lag nicht an denen
auch das parlament muss die gründe dafür
suchen und benennen es ist sicherlich
verlogen immer erst am ende ehrlich zu
sein am ende fragen zu stellen die
fragen die heute gestellt wurden von der
politik müssen die politiker auch
beantworten es kann nicht dabei bleiben
nur fragen zu stellen sie müssen das
beantworten und zwar in der regel bevor
es in den einsatz geht und nicht danach
auch diese bilder gehören heute dazu
soldaten die nicht eingeladen waren
treffen sich unweit des reichstags
zumindest in der nähe sein wenn das ende
des einsatzes pompös begangen wird es
ist ihr versuch abzuschließen mit dem
was viele von ihnen ein körper und seele
verzehrt hat
nun leben also in deutschland mehr als
90.000 mit erahnen soldatinnen und
soldaten die den einsatz in afghanistan
erlebt und durchlitten haben viele in
kampfhandlungen viele mehr die die
feldlager so gut wie nie verlassen
durften den man den eva schiller traf
hat afghanistan fürs leben gezeichnet
was für ganz deutschland verstörende
bilder waren der jubel der taliban als
sie kampflos zurückkamen an die hebel
und an die tröge der macht das kann für
peter hämmerle nur eine verhöhnung
seiner einsätze unter lebensgefahr
gewesen sein eine deprimierende
erfahrung
dieser tag ist einer der erinnerungen
hoch spült erinnerungen die afghanistan
veteran peter hämmerle so verzweifelt zu
verdrängen sucht erinnerungen die ihn
unerbittlich heimsuchen in flashbacks in
seinen träumen in gesprächen mit
kameraden seiner afghanistan bilanz
fällt gnadenlos aus
der ganze einsatz von arch ich sage dass
ich bin schwabe ich sagte es direkt
der seit 20 jahren viele für meine
kameraden gestorben sind viele sind
verletzt wurden leiden heute noch ganz
schwer darunter und der einsatz hat
gebracht gleich null
zu beginn des einsatzes 2003 führt
hauptfeldwebel hämmerle einen konvoi zum
kabuler flughafen ein mit sprengstoff
beladener selbstmordattentäter raste in
die kolonne in einen bus voller
heimkehrer vier soldaten sterben 30
werden verletzt
über diese erste attacke der taliban auf
die bundeswehr möchte peter hämmerle
heute nicht mehr sprechen aber er will
klar machen was das auch jahre danach
mit der seele macht
extreme albträume
also die albträume möchte keinem zumuten
damals hatte man mutig sagt
lieber peter du bist als mein sohn nach
afghanistan gekommen bist als fremde
verzicht sich zurück wie ein
schneckenhaus zum beispiel morgens gegen
der tiefste wald ob regen doch sonst was
ich bin da ganz alleine und da fühle
mich wohl und dann wäre ich da wieder
einmal siedlung meiendorf ankommt dass
ich mir darunter leute
und wenn die regierung jetzt sinn sucht
von entwicklungshilfe spricht und
afghanistan weiter finanziell
unterstützen will dann ist das für
hämmerle scheinheiliges schön reden da
hat jeder gesagt wenn wir rausgehen hier
wenn nato ausgeht dann ist explosionen
dort die zeitmaschine alles wieder beim
alten ich weiß dass die in berlin kommt
weltfremd sind die sind weit weg von der
realität die dürfen doch nicht glauben
dass ein einziger cent an bevölkerung
geht aber nicht ein einziger in
afghanistan die taliban jetzt die zeit
wieder zurück davon ist peter hämmerle
überzeugt aber für ihn und viele seiner
kameraden die nicht so offen sprechen
gibt es kein zurück ihre erinnerungen
bleiben
guten abend frau ministerin
das war heute für alle beteiligten
selbst für zuschauer wie uns in der
redaktion ein emotionaler tag was bleibt
davon bei ihnen persönlich
es war in der tat ein sehr emotionaler
tag es war ein tag der den blick frei
gemacht hat auf die leistungen der
bundeswehr aber auch auf die soldatin
soldaten die zum beispiel unter den nach
belastungen leiden das haben
insbesondere auch die gespräche mit den
verwundeten mit den angehörigen heute
auch noch einmal gezeigt
und es hat deutlich gemacht dass das
land auch in form seiner
verfassungsorgane heute danke gesagt hat
respekt gezeigt hat es hat aber auch
deutlich gemacht wie die lehren aus
afghanistan sind wie die offenen fragen
sind und was ich nach vorne hin
weiterentwickeln muss damit wir bei
anderen einsätzen aus dem was wir in
afghanistan richtig und falsch gemacht
dann lernen können die soldaten dort und
man hat das erlebt wenn man als reporter
hingegangen ist die hatten das gefühl
die in berlin reden von der einen sache
wir erleben hier eine andere da gab es
diese wortklaubereien darum ob das ein
bewaffneter konflikt sei aber kein krieg
ob man die ausrüstung so machen könnte
wie ein krieg oder ob man gewisse
waffensysteme die dringend brauchten in
deutschland zurückhaltend muss weil das
dann ja wie krieg aussieht und all diese
dinge halten sie für ausgeschlossen dass
sich das bei der nächsten
herausforderung wiederholt
es sollte sich nicht wiederholen weil in
der taten das war einer der großen
befunde unseres auftaktes in die
bilanzierung des einsatzes genau dieses
gefühl dass man zwar sein taktisches
ziel erreicht hat aber dass man gar
nicht so genau gewusst hat was es
eigentlich das politische ziel dass
damit verfolgt wird dass die
einsatzrealität und das war für die
soldatinnen soldaten krieg eben in
deutschland nicht in worte gekleidet
worden ist sondern agiert worden ist das
schafft dann auch einbruch von vertrauen
zwischen bundes- wie auf der einen seite
und parlament dass er die bundeswehr in
diesen einsatz schickt und das darf uns
bei den anderen einsätzen in denen wir
jetzt sind in leben wir möglicherweise
in zukunft gehen nicht noch mal
passieren das ist eine der großen leeren
und die sich der neue bundestag die neue
bundesregierung kümmern muss wird das
nicht nötig seien bei dem nächsten
solchen einsatz und vielleicht auch bei
denen die in mali zum beispiel jetzt
noch laufen auch als
verteidigungsminister ministerin klar
und deutlich zu sagen da sind menschen
in einer situation in der sie unter
umständen auch töten müssen und getötet
werden könnten worte wie man am anfang
nie gehört hat das ist absolut nötig
weil es die realität eines einsatzes ist
denn die männer und frauen die in diesen
einsatz gehen riskieren ihr leib und ihr
leben und das auch in einer solchen
auseinandersetzung
bundeswehrsoldaten andere menschen töten
gehört zur einsatzrealität mit dazu und
ich bin immer dafür angetreten und bin
auch bekannt dafür dass ich der festen
überzeugung bin man muss dinge auch beim
namen nennen man darf sie nicht schönen
weil das ansonsten auch eine situation
schafft von der die soldatinnen soldaten
zu recht den den eindruck haben dass in
das verständnis in der öffentlichkeit
und damit auch der rückhalt den sie für
ihren dienst brauchen abhandenkommt und
fehlt muss viele leiten gehörte darunter
muss man diese offenheit als minister
als regierungschef auch aufbringen dann
wenn man weiss ich werde dann dafür für
den einsatz den ich für notwendig halte
weder im bundestag unter umständen noch
in der bevölkerung eine mehrheit
bekommen
absolut weil man um diese mehrheit
kämpfen muss das ist man den soldatinnen
und soldaten schuldig denn liege nicht
selbst in den einsatz zu schicken wir
geschickt die politik die schickt das
parlament in den einsatz und sie haben
es verdient ich hab das eben gesagt dass
sie mit der größtmöglichen rückendeckung
und die kann nur durch ehrliche debatte
und ehrlichkeit entstehen auch in einem
deutschen einsatz gehen ich habe mir
gerade noch mal das mandat angeschaut
für den einsatz in mali der beruht auf
der un-resolution
2100 da werden als die klaren ziele die
jetzt immer verlangt wurden nachträglich
für afghanistan werden da angegeben
wiederherstellung der staatlichen
autorität sicherung von freien wahlen
und förderung der menschenrechte das
klingt verdammt nach afghanistan und
zielen die da nicht erreicht worden sind
wie wird es weitergehen mit mali das
klingt nach einem anspruch den wir in
mali haben zu recht haben von dem wir
aber sehr selbstkritisch auch jetzt in
den nächsten wochen und monaten
überprüfen müssen ob wir ihn erreichen
können ob wir ihnen vor allem mit den
mitteln die wir einsetzen auch auf der
grundlage des un mandates dass er kein
robustes mandat ist erreichen können und
ich kann nur sehr dazu raten dass diese
debatte schnell und zügig geführt wird
auch mit unseren europäischen partnern
denn auch da gilt es muss am ende des
tages um realistische ziele gehen und es
muss in einem mandat dann auch wirklich
festgelegt werden was die bundeswehr zur
verfügung hat damit sie diese ziele auch
wirklich erreichen können das bedeutet
ja praktisch dass sie so wird es ja
wahrscheinlich sein als union dann in
der opposition von der regierung die rot
gelb grün ist etwas verlangen an
robustheit und ehrlichkeit dass die
union 16 jahre nicht aufgebracht hat es
ist etwas was die union auch in den
regierungen immer wieder eingefordert
hat was aber auch mit den diversen
positions- partnern vor allem jetzt in
der letzten koalition so nicht
umzusetzen war insofern habe ich immer
sehr dafür geworben dass wir die dinge
offen und ehrlich auch in ihrer
brutalität wie sie sich darstellen
ansprechen glaube im übrigen dass die
deutsche bevölkerung sehr viel weiter
ist in der debatte solcher dinge als wir
das im politischen raum in der ein oder
anderen stelle für möglich halten wir
werden sehen danke frau ministerin und
einen guten namen und
zu anderen ungelösten problemen die die
scheidende regierung hinterlässt pflege
dauerberichterstattung zu corona hat
dieses kerngebiet des sozialstaates
unter dauerbeleuchtung gestellt die
leistungen der menschen dort ihre
unverzichtbarkeit und die defizite waren
einem jahr ständig vor augen in den
letzten anderthalb jahren und das hat
sich auch ein bisschen was getan mehr
öffentliche wertschätzung auch ein
erhöhter mindestlohn auch wenn der nicht
überall geld und trotzdem die lage ist
heute zum deutschen pflegetag immer noch
davon bestimmt dass arbeitsplätze
genauso davonlaufen wie die kosten da
ist es kein wunder dass betroffene nach
vielen jahren und anläufen zu reformen
jetzt ganz grundsätzlich fragen ob nicht
das ganze system geändert werden muss
henriette de maizière und dj andi
berichten
nach untersuchung vor zwei wochen war
lux schon einmal hier mit starken
bauchschmerzen sein kinderarzt vermutet
blinddarmentzündung look soll sofort ins
krankenhaus und operiert werden doch das
ist in berlin gar nicht so einfach
der naheliegenden klinik sind mehr als
die hälfte der regel betten geschlossen
worden weil eben die personell nicht
besetzt werden können und das ist
natürlich ein unglaublicher engpass für
uns und erschreckend dass wir eben
teilweise unsere wirklich kranken kinder
gar nicht mehr sofort dort eben
stationär untergebracht bekommen das
gesundheitssystem an seiner grenze auch
deswegen wurde über einen monat an
berlins großen krankenhäusern gestreikt
die die in den kliniken arbeiten
schlagen alarm demo vergangenen samstag
es ist gefährlich in den krankenhäusern
deswegen stehen wir hier es ist jeden
tag gefährlich und das licht seit dem
streik sondern seit jahren es ist
meistens so dass ich drei frauen aktiv
unter der geburt betreuen das hatte ich
hab überhaupt nicht wirklich die zeit
mich um die frauen zu kümmern sie haben
tote patienten auf den auf dem flur
gefunden weil so viele zugänge kam in
der von der rettungsstelle
dass man das nicht mitbekommt
was sind die zustände das sind die
zustände nicht nur in berlin viele
halten der belastung nicht stand und
kündigen bundesweit fehlen heute schon
200.000 pflegekräfte in krankenhäusern
ambulant und in altenheim die lage
dramatisch und doch auf dem deutschen
pflegetag in berlin heute ein minister
der mit sich zufrieden ist die
abwärtsspirale ist gestoppt aber
sie ist noch nicht in die andere
richtung so gedreht dass es im alltag
ankommt wie der begonnene weg jetzt
fortgesetzt werden kann
weniger optimistisch klingt das bei der
pflege ratspräsidentin die den notstand
als die schlimmste krise nach der
klimakrise bewertet pflege müsse der
gesellschaft etwas wert sein ihre
konkrete forderung ein einstiegsgehalt
von 4000 euro
mehr lohn bedeutet mehr lebensqualität
bedeutet höhere gesellschaftliche
wertschätzung bedeutet besseren zulauf
besserer verbleib und die chance
berufsrückkehrerinnen zu gewinnen mehr
lohn und insgesamt eine abkehr von einem
system was profit über alles stellt
fordert auch eine pflegenden initiative
gesundheit ist keine ware die pflege
oder gesundheit ist kein wachsender
markt sondern eine wachsende
herausforderung für die ganze
gesellschaft und das müssen langsam alle
menschen verstehen bei lueg ist alles
gut ausgegangen auf druck seines
kinderarzt es wurde er in der klinik
aufgenommen was bleibt ist eine narbe am
bauch und das gefühl dass gute
medizinische versorgung in deutschland
nicht selbstverständlich ist
so viel für diese sendung aus berlin
aber da war noch ein thema die spd will
nach den sondierungen möglichst schnell
an die regierungsbildung gehen
spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz sagte er sei
sich sicher dass das vorhaben gelingen
könne und vor weihnachten eine neue
regierung stehe scholz lobte die sehr
gute und konstruktive atmosphäre
in den sondierungen mit grünen und fdp
während scholz bei der iwf-tagung in den
usa ist arbeiteten heute die
generalsekretäre an einem papier auf
grundlage dessen am freitag entschieden
werden soll ob spd grüne und fdp
koalitionsverhandlungen
aufnehmen werden
abgeschlossen sind die
sondierungsgespräche in mecklenburg
vorpommern zweieinhalb wochen nach ihrem
sieg bei der landtagswahl dort hat
spd-ministerpräsidentin schwesig am
abend erklärt mit der linken
koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen zu
wollen damit würde die cdu aus dem
bisherigen regierungsbündnis im
nordosten ausscheiden
die gesetzlichen krankenkassen benötigen
im kommenden jahr einen rekord zuschuss
vom bund in höhe von insgesamt
28,5 milliarden euro das prognostiziert
der zuständige schätzerkreis von
gesundheitsexperten
grund seien stark gestiegene ausgaben
wegen corona sowie wegen ausgaben
intensiver gesetzgebung üblicherweise
beträgt der bundeszuschuss 14,5
milliarden euro zusätzliche 7 milliarden
waren schon geplant
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
will entschlossener gegen das
artensterben vorgehen in der bei der un
konferenz im chinesischen kunming
verabschiedete erklärung legen sich die
staaten allerdings nicht auf konkrete
maßnahmen fest sondern fordern dazu auf
die bedeutung der biologischen vielfalt
anzuerkennen
umweltschützer kritisieren den text als
zu warten
in der norwegischen stadt kongsberg hat
am abend ein mann mehrere menschen
offenbar mit pfeil und bogen getötet und
verletzt nach angaben eines
polizeisprechers ist der mann
festgenommen worden nach bisher
vorliegenden informationen habe er die
taten allein ausgeführt zu der zahl der
opfer und zu einem möglichen motiv
wurden zunächst keine angaben gemacht
der vertrag der europa und
großbritannien die folgen des brh exit
abfedern sollte droht zu zerreißen an
seiner schwachstelle an der grenze
zwischen dem vereinigten königreich von
großbritannien und nordirland einerseits
und der eu andererseits diese grenze
darf nicht spürbar seien nicht über lang
zwischen irland und nordirland das würde
katholische nordiren empören aber auch
nicht im meer da würde sie protestanten
erregen die großbritannien nicht
loslassen wollen aber irgendwo muss er
eine grenze hin wenn der exit vollzogen
ist und großbritannien draußen sein will
und in dieser forderung liegt brennstoff
die eu beschuldigt boris johnson dass er
mit dem sprengstoff spielt weil er
politisch gerade solchen sprengstoff
braucht jasin herrlein berichtet aus
london
es geht mal wieder um die wurst in
sachen braig sit und nordirland und um
des lieben friedens willen kündigte die
eu heute weitere zugeständnisse an um
die folgen des sogenannten nordirland
protokolls zu lindern zum beispiel durch
die erlaubnis einer kontroll freien
einfuhr von kalbfleisch ware und
vielleicht noch wichtiger medikamenten
die haben unser regelwerk komplett auf
den kopf gestellt um eine solide lösung
für diese herausforderung zu finden
doch bei den briten scheint beim thema
exit ein alter reflex immer noch zu
zünden
chefunterhändler laut frost brachte es
gestern tatsächlich fertig die
vorschläge abzulehnen bevor sie
überhaupt auf dem tisch lagen
mit dem protokoll hat die eu uns
übervorteilt als uns die hände gebunden
waren es kann in seiner jetzigen form
nicht bestehen bleiben
zweierlei ist daran merkwürdig zum einen
hat der frost in boris johnsons nahmen
sämtliche regelungen bezüglich
nordirland selbst ausgehandelt zum
anderen läuft ist dort eigentlich
ziemlich gut anders als im rest des
königreichs hat es hier bisher keine
schlangen vor den tankstellen und andere
transport engpässe gegeben man muss sich
nur mit den begebenheiten arrangieren
wie in diesem lebensmittelunternehmen im
irischen grenzgebiet über
drei jahre mussten wir uns auf den
wechsel vorbereiten wir wussten nicht
was passieren würde jetzt haben wir ein
abkommen das uns erlaubt zutaten aus dem
süden irlands zu beziehen statt aus dem
vereinigten königreich und das wurde von
der britischen regierung auch so
unterschrieben um bis zu 77 prozent ist
der warenaustausch mit dem süden zuletzt
gestiegen während im rest königreich der
handel stagniert das wirft kein gutes
licht auf den bucks it und so sehen
nicht wenige im jüngsten säbelgerassel
aus london nicht mehr als den versuch
von den eigenen schwierigkeiten
abzulenken
es gibt immer noch leute die sich einen
dreck sit in reinform wünschen mit dem
protokoll geht das nicht und dann gibt
es jene die nach einer möglich versuchen
die fehler die großbritannien zuletzt
begangen hat zu vertuschen ein streit um
das nordirland protokoll bietet diese
möglichkeit
menschen wie unternehmer brian ried
möchten nichts weiter als in ruhe ihrem
geschäft nachgehen die frage ist ob die
politiker in london und belfast lassen
angesichts der stark steigenden
energiepreise hat die eu-kommission
vorschläge präsentiert mit denen
verbraucher und unternehmen geschützt
und entlastet werden sollen die
vorgeschlagenen maßnahmen seien einen
werkzeugkasten von bethmann wie
realistisch ist denn die verwirklichung
dieser vorschläge ja wie so häufig in
europa nützen die besten ideen nichts
wenn die einzelnen länder ist nicht
umsetzen deutschland beispielsweise
reagierte heute sehr zurückhaltend die
amtierende bundesregierung plane keine
der jetzt von der eu vorgeschlagenen
werkzeuge einzusetzen
der druck für die neue regierung
allerdings wächst angesichts der
drastisch steigenden erzeugerpreisen
beispielsweise heizöl im august lagen
die preise hier um gut 64 prozent höher
als im vorjahresmonat auch beim erdgas
ein deutliches plus von 44 prozent beim
strom eine steigerung von rund 20
prozent der deutsche mieterbund und der
verbraucherzentrale bundesverband waren
vor einer neben kostenexplosion spanien
italien und frankreich steuern bereits
gegen ohne auf den europäischen
werkzeugkasten gewartet zu haben der
sieht ab sofort vor dass die
mitgliedstaaten energie checks an ärmere
verbraucher verteilen dürfen
staatshilfen an unternehmen zahlen und
steuer auf gas und strom senken können
die preiskrise erfasst inzwischen auch
eon der energieriese teilt mit dass er
derzeit für neukunden keine erdgas
produkte mehr anbietet zu unsicher das
geschäft angesichts der preissprünge
andere versorger schenken ebenfalls ihre
angebote ein was umgehend das zuständige
wirtschaftsministerium auf den plan rief
eine sprecherin beruhigte die
versorgungssicherheit in deutschland sei
weiter hoch mit anderen worten sie ist
nicht gefährdet vielen dank für die
einschätzung
beschäftigte deren arbeit wegen
allgemeiner schließungen im corona
shutdown nicht möglich war haben kein
recht auf bezahlung das
bundesarbeitsgericht entschied in einem
ersten corona streitfall dass
arbeitgeber nicht verpflichtet sind für
den ausfall lohn zu zahlen das sei sache
des staates der die flächendeckenden
schließungen angeordnet hatte besonders
hart trifft das mini jobber für die es
zudem kein kurzarbeitergeld gibt
gegen bayern münchens abwehrspieler
lukas er indes ist die vollstreckung
einer haftstrafe angeordnet worden der
französische weltmeister muss kommende
woche vor einem strafgericht in madrid
erscheinen und soll ab ende oktober eine
sechsmonatige haftstrafe antreten
hintergrund ist eine handgreifliche
auseinandersetzung mit seiner heutigen
ehefrau im jahr 2017 ehrmann das war
damals mit einem kontaktverbot belegt
worden gegen das er laut gericht
verstoßen hatte die gewinnzahlen vom
lotto am mittwoch ohne gewähr 47 10 18
31 35 superzahl 5 weitere gewinnzahlen
auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
mit seiner rolle als captain kirk auf
dem raumschiff enterprise wurde william
shatner weltberühmt nun ist der 90
jährige schauspieler heute erstmals
tatsächlich ins all geflogen zumindest
an die schwelle dorthin als ältester
mensch der raumfahrtgeschichte an bord
einer raumkapsel hoch schöppner von der
west texanischen wüste aus zu einem rund
zehnminütigen ausflug ins all ab möglich
gemacht hat das abenteuer amazon
milliardär jeff bezos kritiker werfen
ihm vor ohne rücksicht auf klima und
forschungsinteressen gelder zu
verschwenden
und es geht auch bei uns auf der erde
weiter das ist ja auch eine weite welt
antje pieper moderiert das
auslandsjournal unter anderem mit einem
bericht über das treiben des sebastian
kurz der mit dem begabungen eines
politischen wunderkindes zwei mal
kanzler wurde und wohl jetzt nach seinem
zweiten sturz als 35-jähriger schatten
kanzler daran arbeitet zum dritten mal
wieder kanzler zu werden es gibt
mindestens in europas politik keine
spannendere achterbahnfahrt als das
außer vielleicht die neue
zeit für unser heute-journal update ist
hier um 0.30 wulf schmiese meldet sich
dann bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend wind ist ja nichts weiter
als bewegte luft und bewegte luft gibt
es zurzeit vor allen dingen hier auch im
rhonetal das ist der mistral dieser
nordwind der das rhonetal entlangläuft
und weit bis aufs mittelmeer hinaus
bläst bei uns in deutschland sind
zurzeit noch schwach aber das wird sich
ändern
schon morgen abend pfeift es dann an der
nordsee ganz gut und dahinter stecken
neue tiefs ein neues tief kommt die
heran tief gerold und das möchte ich
ihnen im verlauf der nächsten zwei tage
zeigen wenn es hat auch auswirkungen auf
unser wetter und verdrängt das hoch
oldenburger sie sehen hier ganz schön
diese kalt vor die bis freitag
weitergezogen sein wird mitteleuropa
dann überquert haben wird und dann polen
und die alpen erreicht haben wird heute
gibt es erstmal legen wollten die von
der küste über die östlichen
mittelgebirge weiter richtung
niederbayern ziehen im westen es dagegen
trocken und zum teil sogar klar und am
alpenrand wird es kalt da sinken die
temperaturen auf +3 bis -2 grad örtlich
ist es nicht völlig ausgeschlossen dass
es auf gehwegen oder auch straßen glatt
sein kann deutlich milder bleibt die
nacht im norden bei 12 bis vier grad und
morgen gibt es ein deutliches nord west
süd ost gefälle bei den temperaturen im
nordwesten sind es 15 16 im südosten
kaum 10 grad und auch morgen über tag
fällt hier im osten noch regen im westen
ist es deutlich freundlicher oberrhein
strahlt die sonne am freitag fällt viel
regen in norddeutschland danach geht es
mit trübem herbstwetter weiter guten
abend